Hello everyone and welcome back to the
channel. Today we're going to be talking
about an adclick aggregator. Uh I
personally have been doing a lot of
advertising recently for my Only Fans
channel. Now you may be thinking,
Jordan, I've never seen one single
Jordan Has No Life Only Fans. I actually
go under a stage name called Sophie
Rain. So if you've heard of that one,
that's actually me. Uh separately, I'm
going to keep being shameless about
this. Uh if you want me to start
responding faster to comments, uh
consider joining the channel membership.
Otherwise, all the videos are free. You
can still comment. I'll still probably
respond at some point. Uh, and yeah,
let's go ahead and get into the video.
Oh boy, I kind of have to poop again.
Let's go get through this. Today, we'll
be building out a metrics counting
platform for advertisements. Though this
one is technically focused on ads, it's
really just a continuation of the tiny
URL video. Basically, as users either
click a short URL or an advertisement,
we want to be sure that we can provide
advanced analytics to the creators of
the content. With that in mind, let's
formalize our functional requirements.
The first and only necessary requirement
is that every single click of an
advertisement should be tracked and that
users of our service should be able to
perform arbitrary analytical queries on
the data. Those queries should return us
insights as fast as possible. For this
video, we'll also list two
non-functional requirements. The first
is that we should be able to query time
series click metrics on advertisements
on a permitt granularity and have those
return extremely quickly. Another
non-functional requirement is getting
data livveness to be within a few
seconds. That's to say, within a few
seconds of a user clicking an ad, I
should be able to see that click
reflected in my queries. Let's stick
with the numbers that we used in our
tiny URL problem. From that video, we
estimated that there were 10 billion
clicks per month to keep track of.
Converting this metric to a per second
basis, we can see that we need to handle
almost 4,000 clicks per second. Before
we break down the exact reasons for all
of our choices, let's map out our highle
design. This flow all begins when a user
clicks an ad and triggers a request
through one of our load balancers and
into one of our application servers. The
load balancer can use a roundrobin
policy because all of our servers are
completely stateless. The first thing
that we do when receiving a click is
check if we've seen it before. This
network call to our duplicate click
database helps us protect against
malicious users who might click an ad
many times to try and earn more money
from their site. If the click isn't
malicious, our application servers then
persist it to our Kafka cluster. We have
consumers reading this data, batching it
up into parquet files, and performing a
bulk insertion into our data warehouse.
Our users can then query that. Keep in
mind that in a problem like this one, we
want to give advertisers as much
information as humanly possible. The
data that we may track may include the
ad ID itself, the ad campaign ID, the
user ID, the IP address, user device
information, the page that they came
from, a timestamp, and more. All in all,
I think it's pretty fair to say this is
a few hundred bytes worth of
information. But to be safe, I'll cap
the data size at 1 kilob. That means
that per second, we're producing 4
megabytes of data. And on a monthly
basis, we're producing 10 terabytes of
data. That's almost as much data as I
shoot out after a few days of not being
able to beat it. Given that the modern
server can comfortably store a few
hundred terabytes of data, we aren't
constrained to using an object store to
support this inflow of data and can add
database nodes to our cluster as we need
to. In the event that we were producing
many pabytes of data per month, we
certainly might be forced to use one.
Many people might propose using a
typical transactional database like
DynamoB for a problem like this one.
That way, we can just write clicks to
the database as they're created and
easily query them back. This approach
has an issue. Such databases may not
actually be able to support the
necessary write throughput. In the case
of Dynamo, for example, a single
partition can handle up to 1 megabyte
per second of writes. In theory, we
should never run into this problem,
right? We could just partition our
database so that ads are split across
partitions based on their advertisement
ID. That makes a big assumption, which
is that all ads are clicked equally.
That being said, if Karina Cobb
advertised free only fan subscriptions,
that could be responsible for the
majority of the traffic. This has been
coined the celebrity problem. The
typical solution for this is to
basically repartition the data for these
popular ads in order to spread it across
many shards. We could do so by adding
some random suffix to the ad ID and then
aggregating back later. Another option
would be to just roundroin clicks to
partitions over database, assuring
better load balancing. But then fetching
all clicks for a given ad would be quite
slow given we'd have to read from all
partitions. In my opinion, both of these
solutions are pretty poor. Let's explain
why. If we want to handle a lot of
writes from a single server, we can use
Apachi Kafka. Kafka is a log based
message broker, meaning that each piece
of data is just appended to the end of a
log file on disk. Because the disk head
only has to move sequentially as opposed
to randomly, writes can occur super
quickly. In practice, a topic partition
in Kafka can handle more than 50
megabytes per second, which is more than
the entirety of the load produced by our
clicks. Hence, we really don't even have
to worry about the celebrity issue for
now, let alone partitioning. Another
great thing about Kafka is that we can
configure our cluster to ensure that
messages are durable. Kafka has settings
to make it so that messages are only
considered valid once they've been
persisted on multiple up-to-date
replicas. At the bottom of the slide,
I've attached some settings which will
ensure that we have three copies of the
data per topic partition and require the
data to be replicated to at least one of
the replicas before a message is
considered valid. Finally, the last
toggle ensures that if our leader does
go down, we'll never fail over to a
replica that isn't completely up to
date. While this may sound like it would
make Kafka super slow, these messages
are replicated in batches, greatly
advertising the cost of the operation
and allowing right throughput to remain
high. From Kafka, we need to sync our
messages into some sort of system that
allows us to store and run expensive
analytics queries on our data. In this
case, we generally want to opt for a
data warehouse or a data lakehouse. In
contrast to your typical transactional
database system like MySQL, the data
warehouse stores data in a columnar
format. Compared to row-based storage,
this results in us storing all data
within a table column together on disk.
Given analytical tables often contain
many columns, but the queries only
require reading a few. This allows us to
just access the subset of columns that
we need, thereby reducing the number of
bytes that we read. Storing all columns
sequentially on disk also leads to
better compression ratios since these
values are more similar to one another.
Finally, operating on data in column
batches as opposed to one row at a time
enables better CPU cache rates and
parallelization of SQL operators via
SIMD instructions. There are many
options amongst OLAP data warehouses and
data links. There are open- source ones
and cloud offered ones. Some of them use
object stores to hold their data and
others store their data with local discs
on the nodes that perform query
computations. I'll inevitably also get
some folks who are going to ask about
time series databases in the comments.
These are a great choice, too,
especially when we want to see ad clicks
over time. That being said, not all time
series databases support running
arbitrary SQL queries. So I'm going to
stick to a generic OAP data warehouse
here. We've already spoken about how
we're sure the messages won't be lost
from Kafka. After our consumer reads a
batch of messages and puts those
messages into the data warehouse, it
lets Kafka know its last consumed
message offset. This way, if the
consumer goes down and comes back up, it
can resume from where it stopped.
However, what we may see now is a
situation where the consumer puts data
in the data warehouse yet fails before
it can report its new offset. We're now
faced with an issue. We may insert the
same row into our database twice. One
option to play things safe would be that
when our Kafka consumer restarts, it
checks the latest row in the data
warehouse from that particular Kafka
partition. It then drops data that it
gets from Kafka in the meantime until we
reach a higher offset than the ones
persisted in the database. This strategy
implies we'd need to persist each row's
Kafka partition and offset in our data
warehouse. It's worth noting that if our
data warehouse supports upserting, all
of our rights would be item potent and
we wouldn't have to worry about this
edge case. However, in many modern data
warehouses, using this functionality
implies that we must first check for
matching rows in the table on each
upsert, making the average operation
much more expensive. Insertions, on the
other hand, just add a file into the
storage system and update some metadata
to note that the file is now part of the
table. Personally, I'd rather just pay a
small penalty on Kafka consumer startup
to avoid much slower data ingestion.
Let's imagine that we had many users
running a query that showed them the
number of clicks over time for their
particular ad. We could very easily run
an aggregation query over all of our
data. However, as we build up data over
time, this may take longer and longer to
run. If we know the minimum bucket
granularity that our clients are using
to see the data as a time series, we can
optimize for this. Maybe our clients
request to see the data at a minimum
granularity of a minute. In our case, we
can run a batch job every single day at
say 3 in the morning to aggregate the
prior day's data in 1 minute intervals
and sort it by timestamp within each ad
ID. We can then take this output and
persist it as part of a second table
called minute data. Would that mean that
we would have really poor data liveness
in that view? Yes. But we can fix that.
When querying for minute-by-minute data,
we combine the results of our
materialized view with an ad hoc
aggregation over the raw click data.
Since the aggregation is basically
limited to 1 day's worth of events, it
should be very fast. Most modern data
warehouses support some concept of
sorting. They may call it clustering.
Internally, we can sort by ad ID and
timestamp to make these queries as fast
as possible. In theory, a malicious user
could click the same advertisement many
times from the same site. How can we
avoid counting all of these as distinct
clicks? What we basically need is a
source of truth. I could have really
used one of these when I was dating my
ex-girlfriend because she gas lit the
out of me. One possibility is
dduplicating data in our data warehouse.
This one again forces us to do something
like upserts, which while functional,
could significantly decrease our
ingestion throughput. Let's think about
the fields that would probably determine
whether an additional row of click data
would be a duplicate. Some might include
the page URL from which the ad was
clicked, the IP address, the ad ID, and
the time at which a user entered the
page where the ad was clicked. We can
hash these fields to create a key that
allows us to figure out whether a click
is a duplicate. We can check whether
we've seen this click in the past before
we actually forward the data to Kafka.
We can do so with fairly low latency by
just using a normal transactional
database. If the row isn't present, we
insert it in the database. If it is,
it's a duplicate click. Since we're
using hashes to determine our item
potency key here, we can easily scale
this across a cluster of database nodes.
The hashes should be evenly distributed,
meaning that we don't really have to
worry about hot shards. In theory, if
someone was really spamming clicks on
one ad and potentially causing a
celebrity issue, they could be stopped
by an IP based rate limiter well before
they even reach the database. In our
design from before, we could probably
get away with just using one partition
of our data warehouse and Kafka topic.
That being said, it's almost inevitable
that an interviewer might be curious how
we would scale out a design like this.
After that, we'll touch upon how we can
not only make the queries fast, but also
ensure that users have access to their
data as soon as possible. When thinking
about scaling out our system, we should
consider what we're actually looking to
accomplish. In our case, we want to
maximize the speed of users queries. One
important question to answer here is
figuring out what the majority of those
queries are looking for. Our clients may
want to click breakdowns per ad per
advertising campaign, which is a
grouping of ad, or even just by the
advertiser ID. To keep life simple,
let's assume for now that it is the ad
ID, though the logic here would be the
same regardless of which one of those it
actually is. In our analytical database,
we'll want to create partitions where
all rows for the same ad ID are in the
same partition. The reason that this
benefits us is data pruning. If a user
is only interested in the stats for one
advertisement, they only have to read
from the relevant partition, and we can
skip reading all of the others, greatly
decreasing the number of bytes to read.
Pretty much all analytical databases
support the concept of partitioning in
one way or another. Some, for example,
BigQuery only support doing rangebased
partitioning. Others like ClickHouse can
take a hash of your partition key,
modulo the number of partitions in order
to determine which one a row should be
sent to. If we really want to scale out
our application, we'll also need to
create many partitions of our click data
Kafka topic. When determining which
partition a message goes to in Kafka, we
have a few options. We can use roundroin
partitioning. We can choose a partition
by hashing the Kafka message key modulo
the number of topic partitions. A third
option is actually just going to be
manually assigning it ourselves from
code. Should we use roundrobin
partitioning? If our main concern is
Kafka being overloaded due to hot
shards, maybe this is the best approach
as it guarantees load balancing across
all of the partitions in our topic.
Personally, I'm not really very
concerned. Again, a single Kafka
partition can handle easily 50,000 or
more writes per second, meaning that our
service can handle an order of magnitude
more data before we should even begin to
worry for us to get overloaded.
Literally every single click would have
to go to one advertisement and even then
we could vertically scale the hardware
running our Kafka brokers. One important
thing to know about data warehouses is
that they typically perform better when
data is uploaded to them in large
batches. This is for a few reasons. For
starters, fewer files of data mean that
query engines have less overhead when
determining all the files to read for a
particular query. The same applies when
compacting data in background jobs.
Compacting a bunch of super small files
uses additional resources which leads to
extra costs for us. Bigger files can
also take advantage of better
compression more than smaller ones. If
our Kafka consumers have a different
partitioning schema than our data
warehouse, then each one will be
uploading smaller batches of rows to
each partition of the warehouse. This is
less efficient. Ideally, we want Kafka
consumers to be handling all of the data
that arrives for a single partition of
our data warehouse. This way we can
provide the largest batches of data to
our warehouse when ingesting it. If
we're passing in parquet files, for
example, one large file will be
compressed much better and result in
much less network and storage overhead
than 10 smaller ones that each contain
onetenth of the rows. For this reason,
we actually want to partition our Kafka
copic in an identical way to how we
partition our data warehouse. Whether
it's hashbased, rangebased, on ad ID,
campaign ID, or advertiser ID, all data
from one Kafka partition should go into
a corresponding partition in the data
warehouse. There are data warehouses
that can support single row insertions
for better data liveness, but we'll
discuss these later in the video because
doing so often has consequences on read
performance. If we have many Kafka
partitions and the load on them is
sufficiently high, we'll likely need
many Kafka consumers in order to handle
the data. If one of our consumers goes
down, we need to ensure that our cluster
of consumers picks up its leftover
partitions while also not resulting in
any duplicate or missed data. This
problem is easily solved by Kafka
consumer groups. When a cluster of
consumers is set up with the same
consumer group ID and configured to read
many topic partitions, Kafka can evenly
distribute the assignment of partitions
to each consumer. Every time that a
consumer pulls in a batch of data from
Kafka and writes it to the data
warehouse, it can commit its last
handled offset back to Kafka.
In the event that a consumer goes down,
its topic partitions will be assigned to
other members of the group and they will
start reading the Kafka Q from its last
committed offset. As we mentioned
before, it's possible that a consumer
will put data in the data warehouse but
crash before it's able to commit its
offsets. In this case, when another
consumer takes over that topic
partition, we just need to ensure that
we read from the data warehouse to get
the highest committed offset from that
topic partition and then drop any data
in our consumer until we surpass it. An
industry standard for the size of
persisted paret files tends to be
somewhere in the 256 megabytes to 1 GB
range. If we're making 4,1 kilob writes
per second, it would take us a bit under
5 minutes to persist a gigabyte of data
to Kafka. Converting aver serialized
row-based data from Kafka to parquet
files can often result in a 2 to 10x
decrease in file size. In that case,
let's flush our data to the data
warehouse every 10 minutes or so to hit
our target file size. This means that
for 10 minutes, our queries won't
reflect recent clicks. Is there anything
else that we can do instead to mitigate
this? While the implementation details
are specific to each data warehouse,
many offer the ability to insert data a
row at a time and have it available to
be queried almost immediately. How does
this work? Under the hood, it very much
resembles our typical log structured
merge tree architecture. Data is sent to
the data warehouse in a row-based format
and buffered either in memory or as a
file on disk. During this time, it is
available to be queried. Because the
data is in a row-based format, this
slows down our analytical queries.
However, the amount of data that's
actually being buffered is small enough
that we're not paying a huge penalty
when querying it in the background. As
this buffered data builds up, we can
perform a compaction job to convert it
into our typical columnar files.
Depending on the data warehouse, this
may just be managed directly for us. An
example of a workflow like this is very
well supported by the Apache Hudi table
format. We can persist small aver files
to the table every few seconds which we
forward directly from Kafka. in the
background after 10 minutes, we might
run a Spark job to aggregate those aver
files into a 1 gigabyte paret file. Well
guys, there you have it. Thanks for
sticking around for video three. Uh I
think in the next video we're going to
start getting into the social media
aspect of things a little bit more.
Maybe I'll do one of the news feed
videos, uh which is probably going to
take a while. But yeah, as always,
please leave any feedback or comments on
things to improve. I really appreciate
you guys sticking around for this long
if you are here. And uh thanks again.
It's a pleasure to do this. and I'll see
you next week.